MAHMOUD ELASSIR:
Welcome to the session
on how Google Cloud's delivering
enterprise transformation
at scale.
My name is Mahmoud ElAssir.
And I lead customer experience
for our strategic accounts
at Google Cloud.
I joined Google in late
2019 after spending
over two decades at Verizon,
where I had multiple technology
leadership roles, like the
senior vice president and CIO
for our files business.
And in the past four
and a half years,
I was the senior vice
president and CTO for IT,
where I led the Verizon
journey to the cloud
with AWS, Oracle,
GCP, and started
the transformation of Verizon
into a data-driven powerhouse.
It's interesting to note how
technology changes so fast.
In 2016, AWS was
the right choice
for datacenter migration,
just like the mainframe
was the right choice
in the '70s and '80s.
Today, it's all
about multi-cloud.
It's all about applied AI.
So I cannot be more excited
to be here at Google,
building our enterprise
experience and teams
and helping our most strategic
customers unlock the superior
capabilities of Google Cloud
and helping them to transform
and win faster.
Our mission in
customer experience
is to help our customer
adopt and realize value
from Google Cloud solutions.
We win when our customers win.
I hope you had a chance to watch
John Jester and Melanie Bragg's
session, which goes
into deep into how
we're investing and building
our customer experience
organization.
Today, I have two objectives.
One, first, I would
like to highlight
how we're orienting our
customer experience to support
our most strategic customers.
Then, I want to
share a few examples
on the work we are doing to
support our strategic customers
across different industries.
We're building deep
expertise for enterprise
in every region
and every industry
to help our customers
transform and win globally.
And this list is
growing rapidly,
with many new kind
of partnerships
that we are announcing during
Next OnAir over the nine weeks
period.
By listening deeply
to our customers,
you, we have built our strategy
under Thomas' leadership.
And we are creating a customer
experience organization
with more depth, credibility,
and enterprise readiness.
Within customer experience,
we have five main pillars.
Our Professional
Services teams now
can help you with
datacenter migration,
with mainframe migration,
and with scaling AI and ML
solutions.
We restructured our Support team
to have more customer context
and to have deeper
expertise in the products
and services of Google Cloud.
Also earlier this year, we
launched a premium support
offering with a Mission
Critical Support option
that will give you
five minutes p0 SLO.
Our learning team recently
launched skills and knowledge
badges and certification
program to help
you build deep expertise
into our modern technologies.
Our Customer Success Team is
continuously engaging with you
to help you accelerate the
time to onboard on our cloud
and to build your
customer success plan,
helping you realize value
faster from our solutions.
And we continuously build
our-- and improve our products
and services by listening
to you, our customers, also
the feedback we get
from our partners.
So that's a huge investment
we're also making this year.
And lastly, so we're building
my team, which is the--
I would say the
Transformation Officers Team.
So this is a team of
industry CIOs and CTOs
that we're hiring to cover
our strategic customers
in every industry.
And they bring two
items to the table.
First, they bring deep
industry knowledge
in the respective industries
we're focusing on.
And two, they bring
credibility of having
led technology transformation
at scale in that industry.
Let's go a little bit deeper
into these transformation
officer roles.
There are three key ways
they help you transform.
First of all, they provide
strategic thought leadership
for you and your team through
this transformation journey
and adopting cloud.
And the way, kind of the
transformation officers
focus on a handful of
clients, up to three customers
at a time.
And this will allow them
to spend lots of time
and collaborate with you and
your team to help you be the--
transform your business
and win in your market.
At the same time, these
transformation officers
will act as the coaches
for our Google side
and continuously
will get our team
to continuously
de-risk the program
and help them kind of think as
be in the shoes of the customer
and build customer
empathy, continuously
de-risking to ensure delivery.
And the third area, these
transformation officers work
across Google and Google
Cloud with other partners,
like Google Health and
Verily and Google Travel
and Google Automotive
Services and Android
and everywhere in Google to
help pool these expertise
to help you differentiate
in your transformation
and deliver faster.
So, as you can see,
you get lots of support
when you work with us.
Here's an example of the
Google Cloud Customer Team.
As you can see, there
are many individuals
on this page, all
of whom are here
to support you through this
journey of partnering with us
and migrating to the cloud.
The transformation
officer play key role
in engaging with you and
your leadership team,
as well as providing
guidance to our account team.
This is a service
that we provide
throughout the delivery.
And it is something
that we believe
differentiates Google Cloud.
Here are a few examples.
I want to start with the
health care industry.
So we just hired Ryan Terry,
who was the business president
at Hill-Rom, which is a
medical kind of platform,
device platform.
He's done lots of transformation
in the health care industry.
So the health care
industry has been
at the forefront of the
fight against COVID,
working tirelessly to
accelerate drug development,
meet heightened demand
for PPE, and rethink
the delivery of patient care.
There are three areas
we're focusing on
with our health care customers.
First one is that telehealth.
The global pandemic has
proven that telehealth
is an effective way
to deliver care.
According to McKinsey research,
consumer adoption of telehealth
has skyrocketed from 11% to 46%.
And 74% of telehealth users
have reported satisfaction.
Our team is working
with several providers
to build clinical and
patient-friendly telehealth
platforms with easy integration
to hospital scheduling and EHR
systems.
The other area is
advanced clinical research
with faster times
to drug approval
and better patient
outcomes is a priority.
We are using our
unparalleled tools
in high-performance
computing and AIML
to develop sophisticated models
to expedite the drug discovery
and approval process.
And finally, we're
working with the hospitals
to enable better decision
making for caregivers
and within business
functions throughout the use
of analytical tools with
more streamlined ways
to access data from
disparate systems.
Shifting gears to the
financial services industry,
and this is where we hired
David Knott as the-- he was
the chief architect at HSBC.
So our financial
services customers
are on an exciting journey
and challenging journey also
to redefine the
banking experience.
They all want to transform the
experience for their customers.
They want to reduce risk.
And they want to
increase collaboration
among their teams.
We're currently partnering
with our financial services
customers to mainly
do a few things.
One, they want to
migrate off the mainframe
and build cloud native
platforms for banking, which
allow them to innovate more
faster for their customers
and change the experience and
be much more nimble and agile.
The other area is they want
to reimagine the customer
experience with the use of
data and machine learning.
And they're building 360
view of the customer, which
is helping them build more
customized and tailored offers
and services for
their customers.
And lastly, we are also
creating new product
with our financial
services customers,
especially when it comes to
fraud and anti-money laundering
and so forth and so on.
And this is where we're
matching their kind of expertise
with our AIML superior
capabilities and talent
to transform and
create these products.
Another industry here
I have is telecom,
and that's dear to my heart.
We have two
transformation officers
in this space to cover
our customers globally.
One is Kevin Shatzkamer.
So Kevin recently
joined us from Dell.
He was the CTO for the
service provider industry.
And the other one is
Frederic Vanoosthuyze.
And he was the CIO at MegaFon.
So Kevin is on board.
Frederic will be
joining us next month.
And we're so excited
to have them.
Our telecom customers want to
monetize their 5G investments
and transform into
data-driven powerhouses
to drive both capital
and expense efficiencies.
They're also
looking for new ways
to innovate and provide better
experience for their customers.
So we're working with
them in three key areas.
The first one is transforming
their customer experience.
So we're launching-- we
launched this product called
Contact Center AI, which
is allowing our telecom
customers to do two things--
transform their customer
experience and their cost
structure at the same time.
Contact Center AI allows
our customers to auto
create both chat
bots and voice bots
with our superior kind
of text-to-speech and
speech-to-text capability,
which is NLP capabilities.
And we have amazing
results in this space.
And this product applies
not just to telecom.
It applies to any
industry or customer
that are heavy on call centers.
The second area, we're expanding
our mobile Edge footprint
and partnering with multiple
telcos in this space
to transform both the consumer
and create new enterprise
experiences that will harness
the power of low latency
and high throughput.
Finally, we are using applied
analytics and AIML capabilities
to help our customers drive
efficiency in their capital
and expense spend
through a tool.
We have a new tool--
I encourage everybody to come
and talk to us about it--
called Network Planner.
Shifting gears into travel
and transportation--
so we hired Ravi
Simhambhatla from-- he
was the CTO at United Airlines.
Ravi has been on board for the
past-- since earlier this year.
And he's been heavily engaged
with our strategic customers
in the travel business.
And there are few
industries that
have been more impacted by
COVID than the travel industry.
And rather than scaling
back their investments,
we have seen our customers
use this opportunity
to accelerate their
digital transformation.
And we are very proud
to be supporting them
during these times.
Some of the key areas we're
working with our customers
across this industry are--
so one is getting them
of their data centers
and getting them
off the mainframe
into our cloud platform and
helping them change the culture
to be much more agile,
build DevOps, and build
SRE for operations.
The other area is they're using
our superior AIML capabilities
and talent to drive efficiencies
in their operations,
and especially their
irregular operations.
Basically, when the
weather, there's a storm
and they need to
reschedule everything, so
how do you use AIML for that?
How do you plan the
last-mile routing?
So lots of opportunities here
to reinvent that business
with our superior capabilities.
And finally, we're also
partnering with them.
And there's an area where we
call Google Travel into this,
and to help create new products
and services for both consumer
and enterprise customers,
and allow them to make
new kind of types of revenue.
So these are a few
examples I share
with you of the work we're
doing across supporting
to support our customers
transform and differentiate
and innovate across
multiple industries.
There are many more examples.
I'm happy to talk about them
more in a different occasion.
In closing, I'd like to leave
you with three key takeaways.
The first one, I hope you
see the customer centricity.
We at Google Cloud are all
about you, our customers,
and helping you realize
value through our products
and solutions.
The second one-- we continue to
make big investments to support
you, our enterprise customers.
The transformation officers
are part of that investment.
But as you heard
from Thomas and John,
we're tripling the investment
in our go-to-market teams.
And that's where we're investing
in our transformation officers
team.
And the third area, you can
see Google Cloud, also we
can pull in all the assets
across-- these transformation
officers will pull in all
the assets from across Google
to help you differentiate your
experiences for your customers
and help you win faster.
I hope you enjoyed
our discussion today.
Here are a few final
tips to go deeper.
And please, do not hesitate to
reach out to your sales rep.
If you'd like to set up
a conversation with me
or anybody from my team, we're
happy to go deeper with you
and answer any kind of
questions or tackle any kind
of opportunities you have.
We look forward to
hearing from you.
And thank you for tuning in.